what's up y'all boy futuristic make sure
you check me out on the bootleg kev
podcast shout out to bootleg cave ain't
you dj head
futuristic is in the building what's
going down what's up man you know just
living a full and complete life how you
doing well you have a baby now have a
baby congratulations almost four months
old it's a big deal crazy change your
life
uh
yeah no like not as much as i feel like
people say it will right but luckily i
have a wife that's a stay-at-home mom
and gets to you know do all handle the
children duties handle the children
duties while i'm out you know trying to
get this money and retire by 40 you know
so it's all good nice yeah um
for people who don't know you're from my
hometown of phoenix yes sir you and i
have a very long in history together
yeah
over a decade first met yeah it's been
10 years yeah we started kicking right
around in 2012 yeah when i moved to
phoenix from vegas
and that was kind of when you had first
started to like i just remember moving
to phoenix and like all the rappers
like i left vegas where like dizzy
wright was popping and sean rose and i
was like [ __ ] man there's like everyone
who i know who's rapping at phoenix is
like 50 and have been trying to do this
[ __ ] since i was a child yeah and i
don't know who sent me your [ __ ]
you might have sent it i don't know i
just said something on twitter and
someone sent me one of your videos
um
and then you would uh that was like kind
of at the beginning of like you really
starting to catch the real national buzz
yeah yeah what was the name of the album
with the dreamcatcher dream chasing down
chasing down the dream yeah yeah
yeah before that yeah so yeah 2012 2013
yeah yeah so um
you've been like independently killing
it for this whole 10 years now little
decade yesterday was the decade mark
since dream big came out my first
professional i was like the cartoon uh
yeah cover yeah yeah
so
what are you up to now you're still
making music of course of course making
music uh always will make music but been
focused on a lot of other things started
a company called indie amplify another
company called maps um and i'm managing
the dudes that just came in here and
went crazy and murdered ocd ocd osmond
benjamin chris rivers anakin michael
minnelli a lot of dope artists i'm
managing now and then um yeah just focus
on indie amplify and dropping music
because i love music just because you
have the luxury yeah yeah indie amplify
is like a that's a great idea yeah
because a lot of people who are
independent
they don't know
where to get like access to like the
easiest things like some people are like
i don't know how to get my [ __ ] on tick
tock with an influencer or i don't know
how to get a feature how do i even begin
to get a feature right or how do i even
begin to get some advice facts even like
um you do like uh consultations yeah
and um really playlisting all sorts if
you if you're trying to get your [ __ ] on
it's like a one
stop shop for any independent artist who
has a serious like you know
anyone who's serious about their craft
who's trying to invest in their [ __ ]
like they could go there and really kind
of pick and choose like what they want
to do right yeah it's like all the label
services at your fingertips basically
where it's like you could book a feature
from an artist you could get uh
consulting from like ace is on there
core days manager um you can get
consulting from adam ivey who's a huge
youtube marketer you can get consulting
from all these people you can get
playlisting you can get
educational resources
content creators social media
influencers everything to really boost
your career and we've had a lot of dope
success stories where you know people
cop a feature for example somebody
copped a feature from me and then
the next thing you know chanel west
coast is trying to jump on the remix
with this person not that that's the i'm
gonna say is that a good thing that's
not that that's the end-all be-all but
what's still being disrespected west
coast but you can get seen by
so many people from working with other
bigger people so you could book dizzy
write for a feature you could book
devonterrell futuristic uh all these
different people for a feature yeah
because you kind of have like
been so self-made throughout all these
years
and you had to figure out a lot of this
for yourself yeah um what like what
sparked the idea to like bring it all
together it literally was every same
[ __ ] you probably go through where
everybody's hitting you up like yo can
you link me with this can you link me
with this can you do this so it was like
after i started like learning the
playlist in game and i built a
spreadsheet a playlist i was like people
started hitting me up like how you want
all these playlists so then i started
playlisting people then people were like
how are you getting reactors to react to
your stuff and it's just like all the
homies already knew right so then i'm
like i'm tired of
middle-manning every single thing so i'm
just going to build a website for people
to get everything so when i had that in
mind i was just like okay what resources
do i really have and it's like oh
features music reviews consulting
youtube reaction videos all this
different stuff and so i just put it on
one site and we take a 20 commission and
everybody if anybody asks me for
anything somebody sends me a link to
listen to their music in the amplifier
in the amplified music review right here
i'm not listening to your music for less
than 100 bucks boom there it is period
and that's that's kind of what i
encourage everybody else to do as well
and not as the owner but as the artist
on the site i made 150 bands last year
just from people booking me for music
reviews consulting and features wow so
you can really live off of it and i
wasn't even our top selling artist who's
your top selling artist um we had crypt
do hella bread on reactions justina
valentine got requested for a ton but
she doesn't accept a bunch of them right
so like if she would have accepted all
of her she would have made like two 300
bands shout out to her she's dope yeah
so you guys have got you guys got stuff
together yeah me and justine have been
rocking since 2000 same time i met you
basically she's went on basically all my
tours jesus i know i didn't know that
yeah yeah she went on
from everything like she did the whole
asking on the internet to her she stayed
at my dad's crib with me in 2013.
so yeah she's been touring with me since
2013. so you made a hunt just not even
as the owner of the site you made 150
bands just off of features and people
paying you to listen to their [ __ ]
advice and consulting yeah yeah because
i feel like the way you kind of came up
like i feel like you and
at the time your producer uh shout out
to matt yeah actually you guys really
kind of figured out facebook yeah
you guys had like the facebook [ __ ] on
lock yeah this was like early on yeah so
where you have like just a like you
built would you say you kind of
originally started to really build a lot
of your cult following through facebook
i know it was youtube as well yeah it
was kind of youtube and facebook
simultaneously like we
we just ran
we had a crazy setup like action is just
a nerd right so dude had like four
computers set up in his house and he had
like a robot that was just scraping
emails off blogs so he was like sending
my stuff through that chain and then we
had like uh we had all the different
facebook post robots doing that and then
we ran marketing literally we we
marketed in arizona to from 12 to 28
year olds they only liked very similar
artists to me and we spent like 50 bucks
every day for like a year
and that [ __ ] just worked we just went
crazy yeah we went super crazy and we
just kept expanding and expanding and
then i started jumping on tours and
yeah i mean it seems like it was a
really long process but it was like from
2012 to 2015 really like it went crazy
yeah what because you know i remember
when you had originally brought uh dizzy
out for your album release party yeah
club red oh yeah kyle i just had kyle
here shout out to kyle yeah kid at the
time that's yeah i'm crazy jaren was on
that show
yeah
so because that was for what what what
album was that for i was chasing down a
dream yeah 2013. yeah that was the
release show um and i remember like how
you doing that record with dizzy kind of
like it felt like it was a big momentum
shift for you when that kind of had when
you guys did the video together yeah and
i know you always preach to
up-and-coming artists like
to
pay for the right feature with the
artist yeah um so kind of give us some
insight into that because some people
are like man i'll pay for nothing like
right at the end of the day sometimes
you pay for a feature and it's like it
change your life it could but it also
could be a waste of [ __ ] money like
if you pay for a young buck feature
yeah yeah yeah i don't know why anyone
ever do that that's crazy um when you
when you get the right feature and the
right demographic like i tell people
this
my ultimate goal and no shade to dizzy
or jaren was to work with hopson right
so i wasn't necessarily trying to get a
dizzy feature or a gerund feature i'm
trying to get a hopson feature so when i
inquired about hopsin they was like he's
got a show coming i saw he was coming to
arizona i'm like i want to get a feature
with him and shoot a video dame hit me
back and was like nah
hopson doesn't really do features but i
got dizzy wright and jaren benton and
these this is dizzy's price and so i did
the song with dizzy for 500 500
is what he what he charged for the
feature and then they had just signed
jaron so they put him on the song for
free they put him on their channel now
obviously this isn't the typical way it
would go but
ideally if you're if you want to work
with a team or a camp or anything like
it's as simple as working with a
photographer that works with these
people you want the person you want to
work with to see your stuff so if you
get in the right teams in the right
camps if it makes sense for your
audience it's a cosign and it's
something that can grow into something
way more so that 500 feature turned into
three more songs with dizzy two tours
with dizzy a tour with hopson
multiple songs with jaren benton like
uh
then weed sponsorships and i don't even
smoke like that 500 has made me way over
half a million wow based off of just
reaching out and getting that right
building the relationship and i also i
always tell this to people i'm like yo
if you're gonna do a feature with
someone make sure that their fans are
super engaged yeah because then you can
kind of like if you're dope you kind of
like steal not steal you know but you
can do you can steal you can kind of
purge some of their fan base to be your
fans that's how i felt about everything
that i did anytime i talk to an artist i
say it's all about platforms what
platform can you get on if i have a song
about weed then how many weed blogs can
i get on how many weed instagrams can i
get on how many weed tick tock pages can
i get on and that was kind of the mode
with everything so an artist another
artist is another platform their
platform is for you and so how can you
capitalize on that to the most so like
when i do something with somebody it's
like okay well let's do like a giveaway
like let's do something to where like
your fans damn near have to follow me
and and my fans have to follow you or
advice you know whatever i can do to
where it's like we're both going to get
the most out of this opportunity and
it's going to be beneficial um so
anytime somebody gets a feature it's yet
and then build on that like don't work
with somebody who's not willing to post
your [ __ ] yeah you want to make sure
that they're going to like actually
promote you and then also like keep
following up on that relationship don't
just do the song and then just and be
out thank you man yeah yeah peace yeah
um
how was it
did you
talk about the strange music tour rules
yeah strange music is wild but it works
really well for me because i'm a super
organized like yeah you're not a [ __ ]
a wild druggie so yeah but dizzy
definitely got fined a few times uh it
all makes sense like strange music is
ran obviously by tech but by travis and
travis has a rule book like it goes with
an iron fist a 30 page rule book of all
this different stuff and it's like
don't like one of the rules is your
girlfriend can't be on the like can't
ride on the tour bus to the next city
well the reason why that's the rule is
because somebody's girlfriend was on the
bus got into it with a rapper and got
her ass knocked out so that's why that's
the reason why there's a rule or like
the reason why fans can't be on the bus
is because a fan came on the bus and and
one of their homies came and shot at him
or whatever and that's why that's a
there's there's a reason for every rule
there's a reason for every rule why you
can't bring wheat on the bus why you
can't do this why you can't do that and
you get fined it's like you get fined
the first time you get fined the second
time and the third time you get kicked
off the tour did you get fined at all i
didn't get fined my dj got fined for i
think missing bus call
and
maybe being late to something and then i
know dizzy got fined for smoking in the
green room like eight times and uh that
was pretty much the extent of our buses
fines but
yeah people get fined for a lot of crazy
stuff and it's it's dope though because
for me it's like i didn't have to do
nothing it was the easiest tour ever
because i'm used to doing everything
right they're handling everything i just
showed up and it's like they got their
own sound tech they got the merch they
got the merch they got a very organized
schedule it's like cool be here for meet
and greet be here for soundcheck be here
for the show were you allowed to do your
crowd dunk on on that tour because i
feel like yeah you were allowed to do it
yeah and that was actually one i had i
told them i'm like i have to do this
this is part of my show cause they don't
crowd surf right and i'm like trust me
i'm not like jumping in the crowd where
nobody knows and the reason why that's
the rule is because somebody got
paralyzed at a tech show from tech
surfing [ __ ] so um or maybe somebody
else was surfing somebody was surfing in
a tech show got paralyzed so for me
though i was like look i'm my thing i'm
all in 155 pounds i i hurdle everybody
up i jump in a specific area never hurt
anybody before in my life i got to do
this and yeah they let me do it
what is something that you learned uh
from from like you know obviously you've
been around hopson a lot but just torn
with tech9 texts like professionalism
and then like you said like you said
just kind of the professional
like way that strange does business it's
very unhip-hop like yeah i think that
was the coolest thing to me was like i
kind of have a compound in arizona
that's like i got my crib i got uh
my my studio house next door i have a
bunch of stuff going on with ryan from
guest list so like i have my businesses
but theirs bro like you could eat off
the floor at any of their facilities
like anything like all their facilities
are so clean everything is immaculate
everything is
just in pristine condition so like the
way that their operation worked was
really dope to see that that's probably
the illest thing that i took away from
it was just like the organization and
the cleanliness of how their ship ran
right um what is something that cause
you know what you met might have did
seven eight nine years ago to get your
[ __ ] going might not be
you know blogs are dead right like ryan
gives a [ __ ] about blogs right like yeah
there's certain [ __ ] that has changed
from a lot now and now that you're doing
management [ __ ] what are the new things
that you've kind of had to even just
adjust to like tick-tock crazy i was
going to say tick-tock is the easiest or
it's not i won't say it's easy but it's
the quickest organic way if you're if
you don't have any money tick-tock is
damn near the only way you can just blow
up and then other than that i would
still say it is still collaborations and
connections and your net worth is really
your network is your net worth you know
so i would say collabs um
main artists with other bigger artists
on spotify um doing that type of thing
and then just the tick tock content and
how you make it i think utilizing every
platform to its fullest and knowing that
like
the real that you make or the tick tock
you make isn't the same thing you should
post on facebook isn't the same thing
you should post on twitter isn't this
every platform you have to make content
specifically for the platform or that's
real yeah or else it doesn't work yeah
facebook's like its own [ __ ] it's its
own thing like a meme on facebook is
gonna go crazy that same reel that you
made turn it into a square make it a
meme and put that on facebook that's
gonna do better than a reel a lot of
times or you post your your reel and put
it in the real section don't just make
it a regular post like
everything is is different like for me
yeah it was blogs and robots scraping
emails and reaching out and like none of
that works anymore um for any art artist
who's up and coming watching this
what is like a good starting place for
like an amount of money they should save
up before they really start kind of
investing and maybe dropping an official
record um
i don't know if there's an amount i feel
like i've seen people blow with zero
dollars i've seen people blow up with
literally no money at all um and go
crazy so
i don't think there's a specific amount
i think it's just what people do is they
get antsy and they put stuff out and
they don't have a plan what i always
tell people is like
however much you spend on the music to
make it you should you should definitely
have that much at least to market it
first of all and then you should always
have a 20-day plan at least for every
single song that you put out you should
have 10 pieces of content you should
have all these things in order you
should have platforms that you've
reached out to um and actually i have a
on indie amplify i have my book i have
an all-in-one bundle that has like all
the contracts you would need all the
checklists you would need um and all the
information you would need to really
i guess take off you know but yeah it's
really just planning your work and
working your plan and i think a lot of
people make music and just post it on
their facebook instagram and tick tock
and don't have a plan for it um russ
shouted you out on trump too yeah what
was that did he open for you in a show
yeah he opened for me in 2015 right
after the greatest came out we did a
show at ole miss and i'll never forget
bro like so
russ is opening up for me
we get to the green room or whatever and
he's it's his time to go on stage he
already has like what they want a couple
other of his songs that are big now none
of them have blown yet he goes on stage
i think he's supposed to do 30 minutes
he did like 15 or 20. he came back in
the green room and i tried to give him
like a motivational speech i was like
bro like you got to just go out there
and like crush it you can't like you
can't quit he's like nah they're ready
for you bro and i and then he said i'm
that that's when i gave him the speech
or whatever he's like it don't matter
i'm gonna be the biggest artist in the
world
and i was looking at him like okay
and then i went and did my [ __ ]
uh it was a college party so we're you
know chilling all night drinking hanging
out playing beer pong whatever and
that's the last time i saw him and then
a couple months later all his [ __ ] just
started going crazy yeah his shit's
out of here it's wild super out of here
but yeah i'll never forget that
literally he was like it don't matter
bro i'm gonna be the biggest artist in
the world
that's that's dope yeah
manifestation man yeah big fat you also
worked with like nf
i i never heard of nf before he worked
with you right he was a christian artist
yeah yeah uh so when you guys worked
together i i had no idea who the [ __ ]
this guy was he's some mysterious white
guy yeah and now he's [ __ ] you know
five yeah crazy going nuts top five of
what just one i'm just saying like top
like he's he's killing it killing it
he's selling out he's doing bigger shows
than most rappers for sure he's gonna do
he's gonna do arenas next year yeah
people don't like acknowledge it because
i just don't feel like he's like he
plays in rap circles if that makes sense
no he doesn't yeah it's always like
that's just kind of hit on an island but
if you talk about like he's got songs
he's got
i know at least one song that has a
billion streams no his videos are always
crazy crazy just his fan base is nuts
but like um you i feel like there's like
a lot of those examples of artists that
you linked up with super early on that
ended up going on to be like super
[ __ ] huge yeah he made a decision to
assign to a major yeah why did you never
make that decision so he was already he
was signed he's like one of the last
person i've ever seen that really got
signed off a talent like he walked in a
label and wrapped for him and was like
this is what i do he got you and they
signed him like so he was already signed
when you guys were yeah he had been
signed for four or five years he
probably got a shitty deal
in the beginning i i believe he did and
then now obviously his deal's a lot
better there's no leverage yeah he's
managed by the dude who manages 21
pilots like he's crushing he gets to do
whatever he wants um but for me it was
like
it just didn't make sense first of all
like i'll make something and then want
to drop it right away right like i i am
very much work off the momentum of what
i'm doing and then i had a lot of major
label things happen to me and i worked
with a lot of major label people and
none of them had none of them were happy
like true i talked with nf about his
deal um i talked with all these
different artists about their deals and
and they all hated it and then at the
same time like hey kyle's back to being
in indy kyle's back to be in india a lot
of people are going that route and so
what happened was i dropped the greatest
blew up i dropped the rise that went
crazy like i made a hundred forty four
thousand dollars first week when my [ __ ]
dropped so first of all you couldn't
tell me nothing how many sales off the
itunes yeah when people were still
copying [ __ ] on itunes so i'm like oh
we're going crazy so after that i
started comparing my numbers because i'm
seeing myself on the charts next to
these people and
i believe that race rimmered had sold 14
000 copies and i sold 12 000.
and i'm just like looking at their album
and i'm like how much did they pay for
all these beats how much how much were
they paying all these artists how much
is their percentage that they get to and
how much did they walk away with and i'm
just like yo
if they got all this promotion i see
them everywhere and they only sold 2000
more copies of me that's crazy and then
i did you know tours and and did jimmy
fallon good morning america and saw the
way that labels were kind of run in that
situation a lot of money was wasted on
that whole thing and i'm just like
i'd be sick like i'd be when you get the
bill yeah there's no way you don't even
have control of how you spend that money
like it just gets spent just getting get
the bill and then you gotta recoup it
yeah you know
i'd be pissed the closest thing what you
had like a little short time with red
bull music right or was that like a
thing that never actually happened i
never signed with them i was meeting
with everybody like i met with atlantic
i i was talking with them really liked
them um
i liked uh dang what's the dude's name
he was eminem's guy
rosenberg no the other dude
i can't remember but there was one dude
that i really rocked with who i felt
like really saw my vision then i rocked
with tick over it at red bull and then
um with wendy at universal republic now
i was really close to signing with
universal republic but that was in
between doing my album i already had the
idea for asking on the internet which
they didn't understand which i don't
know why and then i was doing jimmy
fallon and all that and seeing how that
was playing out then they flew me to new
york multiple times and the main cat at
republic blew me off and i'm like
y'all flew me here it was either two or
three times they flew me to new york to
specifically meet with him and he never
showed and i'm like if you're blowing me
off now what you gonna do when you got
me under contract you're definitely not
coming in
you're trying you're supposed to be
courting me right now did uh strange
ever try to sign you
weirdly strange and funk volume have
never tried to sign me
funk everybody thought that like oh he
turned down funk volume he turned down
strange neither one of them ever offered
me a deal that's interesting which dame
told me he's like you're too similar so
why would i
why would i sign you you're pretty much
already ingrained in our you know fan
base fan base so what what what more
would it add or add to you and add to us
and then it was strange it was like
yeah they never offered me anything
either hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our sponsors
at my bookie now if you're into sports
like me you like to win money
what are we doing go to my bookie right
now man let's get in on some of this
action
my bookie go sign up get the double
deposit bonus that's what this means
when you sign up in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're going to match it
they're going to double it for you up to
a thousand dollars but you got to use
the keyword the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at mybookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're gonna match that give you a
whole nother thousand to gamble with
mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit let's get into some arizona [ __ ]
arizona [ __ ] so early on i feel like um
you got a lot of flack
from uh some of these whack-ass like uh
people in arizona who are supposed to be
like taste makers or whatever because i
feel like
you had a lot of [ __ ] hate in a z
because this was at the time you and i
were like super close and there was a
lot of people who just felt some type of
way that like i had my arm around you
and i wasn't co-signing them mm-hmm
like a lot of people yeah and then some
you probably knew more than me oh yeah
yeah um
but um
you had kind of like did a good job i
feel like of like
not
being a part of like the underbelly of a
z hip-hop that like uh is like
low-hanging fruit yeah
um
and i think that like
in the long run it was for the better
right but like do you remember like that
era where you were getting like kind of
some some some [ __ ] in a z for kind of i
don't know if people thought you were
too good for the scene or whatever it
was but also the scene kind of sucked
it's weird like
but you were doing your own thing like
you were doing the i was the [ __ ] of
club read once a month where you were
but you know what i mean you mean
there's like there was like this little
world of arizona hip-hop and you were
not in that world right and a lot of
those guys felt some type of way right i
think what it honestly it was kind of
crazy when i first linked up with action
it bothered me a little bit but also i
wasn't from there so i didn't really
know like all the cats are talking about
i feel like everybody knew each other
right i didn't know anybody so i was
just focused on how do i get on and the
first show i ever did in arizona or one
of them was opening up for willy norfolk
and
right away i'm like this is not my
demographic i'm never opening up for
this type of crowd again like it just
didn't make sense so then when i linked
with action he was kind of telling me
about like mgk in cleveland and mgk was
the same way in cleveland and we kind of
modeled like even if you look at the
dream big cover that's made by mgk's guy
glen enfante so he was just like yo
there was a cleveland hip-hop awards in
2012 and mgk didn't win anything
and i was like
what
and that was kind of like my road map
where i was just like it doesn't matt it
doesn't matter why are we why are all
the rappers trying to impress other
rappers i'm trying to impress fans i'm
not trying to impress any other rappers
or work with any other rappers or any
[ __ ] like that i'm just trying to get
where i'm going so for me i actually did
a ton for the the arizona scene of
people that are doing [ __ ] you had to
prove it [ __ ] that was going crazy
that's what i'm saying but none of the
artists that were supposed to be
somebody ever did those because they
felt like they were too big for it but
those shows every time were 350 plus
people right and it was because i put
nine acts on the bill that all were
required to sell 30 tickets or they
didn't perform and so
those people that did that now are like
yo that was my [ __ ] that was my first
show ever was doing futuristics prove it
back in the day so i did a lot for the
scene it just wasn't for the people that
felt entitled and
that that was their scene i had a
completely different scene yeah i feel
like a lot of like the old heads in az
feel like real ownership over like
anything that comes out of the state for
whatever [ __ ] reason yeah and like
when i that's why when i moved back i
was like man all this [ __ ] that's been
going on since i was a [ __ ] 11 years
old like i'm trying to do my
right i need to find the new guys right
because the arizona scene was so stale
and it was just a bunch of very old
dudes yeah
that had been rapping there forever yeah
yeah and i was like oh well look this is
futuristic yeah he's a [ __ ] you could
wrap your ass off you were very
different you were very original and
then like obviously there was guys like
sincerely collins
who well
i don't know if we met through you or
not
i know iraq brought him up to the
station i know i showed him to you you
showed me i showed him to you before i
rock you before you talk to iraq about
him um and yeah you didn't like his
music
originally you remember that dude um
renzelle rozelle
he had a [ __ ] v jake did one of his
videos
renzelle
jr
yeah jr was hard he was fired he lives
in texas um he changed his name yeah to
that to the weird name who else was dope
i mean obviously v who i know you guys
never really saw eye-to-eye uh yeah
um
i'm trying to think that era that was
just like merkem's was doing his thing
still back i didn't remember i didn't
know mercum's background really yeah me
and mark's got a joint from like 2011.
like we've been i've i've known him for
that long um
yeah i mean
yeah terrain
preem i i don't think i knew of preen
back i didn't know if preemptive i knew
of toray i didn't know of preem um
but yeah what was that cipher who was a
part of that cypher when you came up to
the radio station
what cypher remember we did the ready
set radio one year anniversary cipher it
was like uv
uh you were it's on youtube bro i don't
remember that we got super shit-faced
i forget who the [ __ ] was on this i
don't remember it at all i know we did
one with collins and markell
no that was that was the one that we
shot at uh iraq's studio iraq's okay we
did like a radio cipher i really don't
remember that at all i'm trying to think
who else was on there
i don't remember
[ __ ] it was so long ago your boy's
looking it up
hannah balek was on that hannibal leg i
kind of i kind of remember being in a
room with that with that group it was
hannah bulleck the lyrical miracle
spiritual guy um
i rocky tirade
he was in it i don't think i was in that
you were in it i think i was there i
don't think i was in it bro you rapped i
remember you like
i remember everyone i remember mostly
everyone kind of [ __ ] up except you
hold on let's pull this up ready set
radio no idea do not remember this at
all
cypher
oh collateral remember the white oh yeah
he was part of uh wax society
[ __ ] with he loved
society
their whole [ __ ] thing was lit they
don't exist anymore i know they were
dope i remember they had the little dude
who like looked like a model and then
they had the guy who worked at zoomies
josh
uh [ __ ] you're in here rapping there you
are look this is your rapping let me see
i probably have a [ __ ] jean vest on
too don't i probably dude
that's definitely all right you're in
here somewhere i don't know where the
[ __ ] i don't think i wrapped bro you
wrapped this
look i'm just talking
i'm not rapping this is on the internet
buddy
that's it
yeah it was 2013 august 2013.
no recollection of that wax
society yeah
they did approve it
crushed it the first prove it ever they
refreshed her yeah they headlined the
first one there's some dope artists out
of arizona that just should have kept
going
for sure somebody in that group should
have just broke away solo i guess they
tried right i don't know t called it the
bigger cat t call was it
t call him hosted his mixtape yeah t
call was part of wax he's on that
wrestling rap [ __ ] shout out to mega ran
too megan ran's also been
supporting his his life through music
for a very long time yeah random i ran
into him in london or paris one of the
two we both had a show in london or
paris the same night mega ran the legend
mega ram great guy facts um what do you
like like i feel like you're like a
little bit more involved now in like
just local [ __ ] in jail yeah yeah yeah
definitely when i moved back to arizona
probably the same way you felt right
like when you left and then you came
back you were like yo like i want to do
something different yeah um and so same
thing kind of happened for me right away
i like tried to dive into the scene and
see what was going on and the first
thing i did was go to uh a full moon
fest you ever been to full moon out
there or even heard of it
crazy one of the illest things like
packed out over a thousand people at
these festivals and they do them every
full moon and so it's like five or six
stages it's a lot of that crystal [ __ ]
you were talking about like a lot of
sedona type rapper uh stuff there but
certainly collins was headlining nah he
wasn't he wasn't at the ones i went to
um but that's where i discovered color
eight the band that i had going end up
going on tour with me this girl truvon
who ended up living at the sheesh house
for a while um and a lot of different
other artists was just going crazy and
so right away i kind of dove back into
the scene and i've just been i don't say
i've been discovering talent because
they've been doing their [ __ ] for a
while but yeah i found a lot of you've
been like helping a lot of people for
sure yeah yeah yeah like is that kind of
like what you're cause you know when you
inspiration wise where do you get the
most inspiration is it helping new
artists now is it the indie amplifier is
it still your own music
it's it comes in waves right like
there's sometimes where my whole focus
definitely my i'd say my main motivation
is seeing other people succeed like when
i got oswin on the mers tour like i was
more excited about that than the last
time i got booked for a tour right like
seeing oz perform kill it sell merch
make some money gain fans like that was
so dope to me and then seeing artists
like michael minnelli and getting him
features and dizzy wright loves michael
minnelli is he signed to you yeah mike's
with me too so all that different like
that i love that love seeing artists win
um the what j-rob just did in the city
is super fire um yeah you just
yeah so i love that and then indie
amplify is just an extension of that
really everything that i do is kind of
an extension of that in the amplify maps
it's all an extension of helping other
artists and seeing other artists succeed
so yeah i mean a big part of my
inspiration comes from helping others
win and what's crazy is it's always been
like that like i tried to sign ali tom
and equate back in the day i was i was
helping collins a ton back in the day
obviously yes you were the stuff with
devon
yeah seeing devonterrell win was amazing
yeah he's dope everybody that i've
worked with and and even when kyle blew
up like dude kyle was a kid when we
first started working so we're clear
which color we're talking about kyle
super duper super duper cow like
going to his crib like he was a meter
maid like kyle was like mobbing around
the city like being a meter mate
checking meters and [ __ ] when i first
met him and um obviously he was working
with jake and doing all that and then
seeing his blow up was amazing to see so
like yeah man it's always been i've
always loved to watch other people win
who are you a fan of in the city right
now that is not associated with you
officially
who's not associated with me um
somebody people don't know
is vinjay vinjay lives in the city um
he's not from arizona but he's crushing
he has like eight hundred thousand
monthly listeners binks is in the city
um
he crushes writes amazing music
um
obviously alexis isn't uh associated
with me love his music
young reese it's really dope
young reese is doing he's a smart kid
too yeah i listen super great kid listen
to j rob all the time love jay rob's new
princess is killing it merkums is
killing it uh i think merkem's is kind
of doing like a
evolved version of what you were doing
back in the day it's the same circuit
yeah it's like the same circuit just as
far as like relentless internet just
going crazy yeah going crazy yeah i love
that for mercums for sure uh and me and
him actually had a really good
conversation because he had a little
chip on his shoulder for me
cause we that song that we did i shot a
video and i didn't put it out no i
didn't put him in it
oh
but you gotta understand the way jake
works is like me and jake was roommates
or me and jake hung out all the time so
jake be like yo let's shoot a video
today let's let's rock
and either i hit murkham's or or i
didn't and we shot the video real quick
and we just did my my verse and so
merkin was like yo you cut me out the
verse yo i did this and you didn't do
this
that sounds like him so this is just the
accent yeah it's not the griping i'm not
saying he's a big complainer he had a
little chip on his shoulder so when we
did the cipher he told me about it a
little bit and i'm like yo i completely
understand but like for me i can
genuinely say i've never
not wanted anybody to win like i've
always wanted people to win
why has um because if we're talking
about success it's either you or mc
magic out of the state of arizona
no i'm not talking about keanu laday and
you know [ __ ] injury reserve injury
reserve two is up there injury reserve
injury reserve has been doing their
thing for sure they kind of have like
the um
yeah they're like doing a really good
shot i forget the kid's name who man oh
i don't know who manages the white kid
uh [ __ ] the producer that's in the group
or is it somebody else no there's a
white dude who manages them doing a
great job okay but um but yeah like i
would say it's unmc magic as far as the
faces of arizona hip-hop of all time why
do you think um no one's ever really
like exceeded what you've done
dude i work i work harder than everybody
i always have like i
i can't sleep like i can't i can't do
like music and business runs through my
mind 24 7. so when my mission was to be
a big artist there was no way he was
going to stop me like that's not my
mission now my mission is in the
amplified to be 100 million company so
that's gonna happen
my focus back then was i have to make a
million dollars by the time i'm 25 off
music period it's gonna happen and so i
was just relentless every day every
night well no matter what it was you hit
me at [ __ ] eight o'clock the show's
at nine we're going to tucson boom i'm
in the car right you know i'm saying
like it didn't matter i live i eat i
breathe i sleep music all the time so i
i really think that's it and then i feel
like nobody does their [ __ ] research
nobody does their research and nobody
has the business mind to really like
take it there a lot of the times i think
work ethic is like a big deal i think a
lot of people who could have made it out
of az were very entitled and they like
like you know i [ __ ]
just in general whatever city you're in
like a lot of local artists might be
talented but they always have an excuse
why they're not bigger that doesn't
start with themselves
yeah it's always someone else's fault
yeah i i never really had that i just
felt like i'm gonna get there i don't
know how or when so i'm just gonna do
everything until it happens and i'm not
gonna stop like no no second in my day
was ever wasted like i'm working
how big of a
career move was it for you to move to la
for a few years because i i do think
that that is important yeah yeah uh i
mean everything popped when i was here
and it's kind of weird because even
well the producers let's just say that
that album the rise was mostly produced
by la producers so while they weren't
super popping people if i wouldn't have
met them i wouldn't have that record the
greatest so uh shout out to d capo when
i met him i i think he produced five
tracks in one day that all landed on the
album um as far as like lincoln with
dawes he's actually from arizona so the
youtube guy yeah what blew me up was the
nerd rap but if i wouldn't have came
here and met them did you meet dawes out
here no i met him in arizona okay okay
yeah so yeah moving to l.a is crazy
because it's like
you never know what you're gonna walk
into you never know who's gonna be in
this room it's just a networking thing i
think it's like it's crazy but i don't
know my mine is kind of weird because
i don't fee as much as dope as it was to
be here i don't feel like
any major career moves necessarily
happen here but maybe just getting away
from all the [ __ ] and
being
being here i don't know
because you and jake were out here
together right yeah living with jake was
big um because we're shooting videos
every single day and then yeah like for
the as seen on the internet album like
there's big youtubers in every single
music video
you know so i definitely made a lot of
connects here you say that like you're
relentless with this [ __ ] how much
sacrifice did you have to make in your
personal life to get all of it to this
point all of it like there wasn't there
was no personal life i didn't have a
personal life it was literally like i
was working 24 7. and i'm i probably
toured like 200 days out the year back
then right so yeah i'm either on tour
the crate this is how crazy it was i
booked the ad scene on the internet tour
before i made the album
oh wow i didn't even make the album i
got i i started booking because to book
the shows overseas my agent was like we
gotta have this much time like cool
we're dropping in august i didn't have a
single song made
so you were like all right now we have a
deadline now we have a deadline and
that's and that's how i've always been i
set deadlines for myself and then i make
the [ __ ] right
hey we gotta stop the podcast man real
quick appreciate y'all for watching uh
really mean mean it subscribe like leave
a comment even if you're one of those
[ __ ] who leaves a comment yo why
you always interrupting the guest
because it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
for a hardest um you know distribution
is like a thing that's pretty easy easy
to come by now um
tunecore distro kid
you know empire united masters whatever
it might be right like what would be in
your opinion if like an artist was
trying to choose between like where they
should upload their music
i think in the beginning distro kit is
the best bet because there's more tools
to to distro kid and not everybody's
going to get signed to empire or things
of that nature united masters is dope
because they do a better job with the
placements but for me
i've just seen the distro kit is the
most responsive and then they have the
dope options for the split for the split
the splits is important the splits is
crazy and i don't know why every other
addition i don't i don't know why i
don't understand why nobody else is
doing it how they're doing and i just
hopped on tunecore like three days ago i
was like i wonder if tunecore is updated
it's crazy because that's one of the
biggest headaches as an independent
artist is to make sure a producer
because maybe you can't pay for the beat
but you could say hey i'll give you a
big chunk of the stream that's why as as
an upcoming artist i would use distrokid
because you can give your manager their
percent you can get all through the
whole you can give any anybody that you
work with it does accounting for you
low-key it does the accounting for you
which when me and when me and devon did
our stuff it was like i had to every
month that was a distrokid that was on
tunecore so i had to go through the
account and be like okay we made this
much here's your percentage here's
ryan's percentage here's mine here's the
producer and i had to do that every
single month when the checks came in or
when the you know the payout came so
distrokit is dope because i can just
assign everybody their percentage and go
yeah russell is uh does something dope
where he like he'll let you invest in
his [ __ ] who does that la russell he's
uh he's have you heard him uh-uh he's
fire he's from uh he's from vallejo
russ just signed him
he's the first artist russ has ever
signed but he does this thing we're like
how rust signed somebody named la
russell the russell's gas though
russell's crazy but he like if like
let's say wallow or
like he was on the breakfast club right
and he was like man when i was on the
breakfast club this [ __ ] put me in a
different space so i gave charlemagne a
cut of this record yeah he's like uh
you know like we we did some [ __ ] on my
show and like he gave me a cut of the
record like right um but he has this
thing where you can like kind of invest
in his songs like their stocks oh yeah
that's super dope so like you might be
able to pay i don't know i don't know
you know i haven't i haven't really
invested but i know that you could it's
it's all through distrokid but like if
you're like if you believe in this kid's
future you could put down x amount of
dollars and own x amount of the song or
whatever that's hard that's super hard
and then the other thing he does is dope
is like he sells merch
but he says pay what you want so when
you go on the website
you could you could buy the merch for
whatever coldplay started that uh maybe
they didn't start it but i remember
coldplay did that with an album they put
it on bandcamp and you could pay what
you want and they did an interview
talking about and it was like some
people would pay 200 for it so all the
people that downloaded it for free
you're you're getting that's getting
made up because somebody's paying 20
somebody's paying 40. somebody's paying
50. whatever it means to them they're
paying for it and it's like
it's kind of like that with everything
like if i go somewhere and i really
enjoy the service it's like yo i'ma go
above and beyond and tip like if you
hook me up every time like boom here you
go so it's kind of the same thing with
with that so it all it all evens out are
you doing are you still like um
because i always say like you know you
have a cult following right and that's
something that
i uh you know i i was talking to uh you
know caskey and tony choc they just did
an album yeah but caskey had a bunch of
unreleased songs
and i was like yo why don't you sell
these bro do you so he sold i do it
every year he sold like uh thousand of
them for a hundred bucks
right like just usb drives or or a cd
but i know you've done that where you'll
sell like a burnt cd yeah i do it every
year so that's kind of like my christmas
sale so like technically you can't sell
the songs because producer producer this
and that's whatever i don't sell the
songs i sell merch and i just put that
cd in the order so at the end of the
year any songs i did like say i drop an
album or two albums that year okay well
these 30 songs it's usually about 30
that didn't make the cut put them on a
cd or put them on a qr code on like the
tag and then when people get the merch
they just scan the tag and they got 30
new songs
damn so yeah i it's a nice incentive to
get people to spend some money so then
i'll mess around and i'll sell 500
pieces of merch and it's like boom you
all get these unreleased songs and those
songs will never be on anything you guys
are the only ones that have them no
one's uploaded them on youtube yet nah
weirdly weirdly i haven't really i
haven't looked but
there's yeah yeah so maybe there's a few
but not for me
yeah i always tell people i'm like i'm
like you know i've been telling ritz
forever i'm like fritz [ __ ] sell a
cookbook with a usb drive attached to it
with like three unreleased songs don't
make a [ __ ] million dollars bro
everything the way i've looked
everything is money like being you can
monetize everything yeah it's a hard
like it's funny because you i i had to
get later on in life to really start
looking at things through that
lens right
like giving away your time for free
giving away advice for free like i'd
give tons of advice for free but just
time to me is like the biggest thing
where if someone's like yo
i'm in town i want to pull it i'm like
bro like
just send me like a private playlist and
i'll try to throw it on in my car but
like i'm not going to come to the studio
and sit with you for two hours yeah no
way but um
when did you feel like you started to
kind of when i was five
he's like it's been in me when i was
five men ain't on me my i blame it on my
dad my dad's a tight wide bro like dude
does not like to spend money at all so
like
from the jump it was like anything that
i if i wanted something when i was a kid
i had to work my ass off to get it so it
always kind of stemmed from that and
like dude i was selling mini discs in
first grade i was selling mixtapes in
third grade like i was really cuz your
dad was a drummer my dad's a drummer
bass player dj
uh
yeah one stop shop one stop shop wedding
and quinceanera by himself yeah facts no
he's he's i think he told me the other
day he's done 800 plus weddings or
something or over a thousand weddings
yeah he he crushes and he's still doing
it he's 63.
so yeah no just that that mentality has
been him from day one so like my brother
was like let's do this show i'm like how
much we getting paid we're not i'm not
doing it period there's no i've i don't
do anything for free because if i'm
gonna spend that three hours at the show
that's time i would spend now with my
wife or my son or family whatever
or spend grinding to get money or even
like the reason why my feature rate is
what it is is because
that time and that energy and then my
platform is worth that amount of money
so it's just and if you do a feature
you're promoting it
for the most part so the way indie
amplifier works is you can click what it
what you want so my base price is 2 000
for me to just do the record and never
say [ __ ] about it you want me to be a
main artist that's an extra thousand you
want me to post on my ig story that's an
extra 150 my main page extra 350 shoot a
video 600 so
depending on what you want my feature
could be two bands or five
and the main artist is is the play
though because then you're kind of dumb
if you don't do that it's the difference
for me between like first week that
artist getting maybe 5 000 streams or
getting 60 000 straight yeah no for sure
so that's a bad that's not a bad deal
yeah so if you get the feature you might
as well get the main artist or else it
doesn't do have you turned down anything
because it was so ass
yes for sure but i accept more than
anybody else definitely because it's my
platform so like i want to show good
faith like yeah book on my platform and
i'll do it but i've definitely turned
down a few
would you ever um
like now that you have other artists
that you're working with like
do you do you advise them like we're
going to stay independent or is there a
major situation because i mean obviously
like you said i mean listen we talk to
artists all the [ __ ] time and they're
miserable in their situation for the
most part right um
i feel like nowadays more than even when
you were on the come up
like a major really isn't all the way
needed like maybe if you like really
want to have a number one record right
right i think it's just what do you want
i think that's probably to an upcoming
artist
you have to think about what you want
and that's the only way i can advise
somebody like what's your goal what's
your dream what are you really trying to
do and i think when people really think
about it like don't answer it now answer
it later do you really want to be the
biggest artist in the world do you
really want to have a number one song do
you really want to not be able to go to
the grocery store without getting
recognized do you really want to like
have all this [ __ ] or are you just
trying to live off your music and if the
answer is you just want to live off your
music and push it out whenever you want
that might not be the scenario for you
and at the end of the day it's like i've
never been anti-label as much as people
think that i am
like i said i was very close to signing
a deal it's just like it didn't make
sense so if a deal presented itself for
michael minnelli who's an incredible pop
r b singer
and that's what he wanted to do let's
run it let's take every meeting we
possibly can and if it makes sense let's
do it yeah think about someone like kyle
right who have i don't know if i spy
happens if he's independent
i spy did happen while he was
independent well with indie pop and then
he signed after like two weeks of it
being out to atlantic right right right
yeah i think so yeah yeah so he dropped
it and then was like atlantic was like
we're signing you and so he signed to
atlantic and i'm sure he's got a
favorable dude i think it's did he tell
us it was diamond
eight times platinum it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah well that i don't know if that's
going eight times platinum without an
atlantic record it's not it's not it's
probably going one one times platinum
yeah without atlantic or gold or
something yeah yeah
um what besides in the amplified you
mentioned maps yeah so maps is like a
new lincoln bio service where you can uh
better create your link in bio
yeah which is important much doper works
way better has way more analytics um you
can it has google analytics integrated
into it i'm gonna say because like the
lincoln bio thing or whatever that smart
link [ __ ] is what everyone uses what
what about that did you see and say we
could improve on this so the design i'll
show you the design of it is way better
and the analytics so like you don't
really know what you're getting how
people are clicking on you on it and
ours is just like this looks way better
so if someone clicks on your bio this is
what they get that's what they get you
don't have to build another website
either that's your website you know what
i'm saying it looks good you can design
it low key like a little mini website
yeah you can you can pick your your your
uh different templates we're
incentivizing people to create their own
templates and then they can sell those
and make money off of them so this is
your new album coming out don't want to
be famous that one dropped on new year's
yeah okay
all right that's fine you know what i'm
saying so yeah it's just a much better
thing and then on the back end like the
analytics are crazy you can see how many
people clicked on each different thing
you can see who purchased something is
the goal to uh
build indie amplify up and sell it
my goal for indy would be to sell it for
100 mil and be hired as like creative
director for it like still be involved
but yeah just get it yeah same with maps
i mean yeah i could see it man i just
think that like
what you what indie amplify what's dope
about it is just like
there's when we think of music and being
an up-and-coming artist and the like
headache of like trying to figure [ __ ]
out trying to like get over the hump
there's access is such an important
thing that people
don't know how to get yeah it feels like
everything's just in one place where if
you're an up-and-coming artist
that's the thing too like we act as a
holding company so if you want the
feature from somebody they have to do it
before they and you have to approve it
and once they send it back it's like
boom it's been approved
what is the biggest um
feature on the site that's the most
successful is it people buying youtube
reactions is it the advice is it the
features
it's three things it's features youtube
reactions and playlisting
why youtube reactions why do you think
those are so important we're the only
place you can get them everything else
that's on our site there's other sites
where you can besides features and
youtube reactions you can buy them in
other places right you can get
playlisting from many different places
you can get music reviews from a couple
other sites you can get all consulting
whatever but as far as like buying
features from established artists and
getting youtube reactions there's no
other site that exists to get those
things but uh for people who don't
understand youtube reactions in that
world why is why are they important for
youtube reactions is almost like the new
blog like if you can get a big youtuber
to talk about your project or your
record then now a bunch of people are
like crypt has 1.2 million subscribers
if crypt does a youtube reaction about
your song now his 1.2 million
subscribers are now going to see that
and go check out your song it's a cosign
i know because i've been seeing like uh
that shit's like i feel like i i maybe i
was late to the youtube reaction party
probably yeah but like it's been around
for a hot minute i was like oh it's like
five years this is a thing yeah and some
of these [ __ ] videos get like
millions of views just some guy talking
about what they think about a [ __ ]
record yeah it's it's honestly really
weird to me but it crashed and it's just
normal people that really don't know i
mean i'm not saying they don't know [ __ ]
about music but they're just youtube
personalities youtube personalities they
watch your stuff and
it they could they could blow up a
record
for the playlisting side like you know
there's like certain tools that if
people have the time the
patience to dig through like chart
metric or like some of these websites to
like try to find curators for playlists
you pretty much kind of eliminate
all of that all the work yeah that was
all the work that i kind of put in for
myself when i was changing like in 2019
i kind of started making different types
of music and that's when i really got
into playlisting because i was like okay
my fans aren't necessarily going to love
this music per se how can i get it in
front of new fans and that's when i just
started going like discovering artists
that were similar to the new music i was
making and looking up all these
different playlists and so once i kind
of vetted that i put all those curators
into a spreadsheet and now and you'd get
their contact
so essentially you're like cool i need a
price to get boom boom boom exactly and
then now when somebody books it's like
boom here's i pitch it to these people
and then they can put it on they can not
put it on whatever the case may be um so
yeah when you get the playlisting if
your songs if your songs ass period
doesn't matter what you do it's never
going to blow up have you had to tell
someone that when they pay you for the
advice like this [ __ ] just isn't good
yes
yeah and it's hard to do but it's really
not that hard to do because i've been
doing that [ __ ] on ig live during the
pandemic
like what do you do buddy
i work at a quick trip
keep that job man right see that's i i
think i
i just know how that feels to be like
the artist and want it so bad
and then somebody be like yeah you suck
but at the same time there are really
shitty artists that blow up
i was just listening to some [ __ ] in the
car today it was [ __ ] awful and has
84 million streams it's it's viral on
tick tock he
shout out to my guy young lean i just
listened on youtube
huh that was nice white guy right that
was not good bro right white guy named
jungling it's not it's like
and i'm not the end-all be-all for
judging music but like it's not mixed
good i mean that yeah i mean that's
welcome to the soundcloud area it it's
just it's crazy to me it's not on key
the beats not good like none of it is
good but it has 85 million streams and
he's [ __ ] on me so shout out to
young lean but
if if he would have played that [ __ ] for
me i would have been like trash this
this is garbage and here it is sometimes
i just get super bored and like
i was at a dangerous manager's house
recently
shout out to that guy brock he's a
[ __ ] young megawatt
interesting guy um
i don't know so there's some chick in
there right and she's a rapper why you
whispering i don't know
[Laughter]
so i was just bored i was like give me
the [ __ ] out of this place it's like i'm
too old to be at brock's house on a
[ __ ] friday brock is too old to be at
brock's house
so i'm like hey this chick is in her 30s
i already knew her music was going to be
terrible you know who she is yeah i
don't know her name okay
so i was like just bored with alexis and
his girl and i was like
let's just entertain ourselves hey hey
you rap oh [ __ ] play me your [ __ ]
she throws it on you're an [ __ ] it's
like the worst music i've ever heard
right so i i literally with a straight
face i looked at her and i said hey
what do you do for a living she was like
i'm like a
medical assistant whatever i was like
listen
whatever it is you got it you need to
quit your job
and you need to go all in on this [ __ ]
cause you got it this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
[Music]
it was great
it was great i don't know if she ended
up now what happens if she really quits
her job
she's all in
she's all in
that being said it was [ __ ] terrible
god bless her shout out to dan g man
sweetheart i love that guy no no
but that's tough that's tough it was fun
though that's super tough but i was like
yo this [ __ ] this is it i was like i
don't know what the when they talk about
it you got it you got it oh man with
your job put all your money in you were
drunk no i was sober i was just bored
damn
boy be the new drunk sometimes for sure
yeah i was like all right this let me
entertain myself tonight i was probably
mean i probably should hit her up and
tell her that her music is atrocious and
not to quit her job keep your [ __ ]
job sweetheart if you're watching this
keep your job please make a watch show
your show your terrible friend this this
video so she does not quit her job i'm
going to post it on my facebook because
i know i'm cool with megawatts on my
facebook i'm gonna post this specific
clip that guy had an afro in an lmfao
ripoff group back in the early 2000s i
remember that yeah that was when i was
like going to access radius the 18 and
up clubs that was cringy yeah
i don't i don't i don't necessarily
remember the music i just remember it
wasn't good it was good
yeah yeah i was like dang these dudes
are popping they're performing at these
clubs and there's a hell of people here
yeah
shout out to access radius yeah shout
out to arizona all the 18 there's like
no 18 and up clubs anymore that shit's
dead nah bro the game has changed the
game has changed game has changed any
other obviously you own guest list uh
your co-owner guest list with ryan which
is a dope store in arizona mills yes sir
yes sir um anything else you got coming
nah man just support the homies all the
homies uh that i manage michael minnelli
ozil benjamin chris rivers elisa
gutierrez
poetics
uh
go to indie amplify make you a map page
and you know music dropping all the time
you all miss out
another album 16 albums in 10 years what
we talked about 16 of them 16. is that
including like the joint album with the
devon yeah
um would you do another join out well
you did a joint with mike michael yeah
yeah yeah did one with mike yeah
all right well shout out to futuristic
go follow him uh go to india amplify
is it kind of like you were telling me
you were kind of like gonna do like a
social media aspect of it where people
could sign up and have their profile
type [ __ ] yeah so what so that kind of
was like
we basically broke that off into maps so
it's not necessarily a social media
profile but we we built maps kind of to
be that and then we realized like people
outside the music industry could use
maps so that's why are you looking for
investors for indie amplify or anything
like that we will be soon we will be
soon it's a great idea yeah we we got
investors for maps um and the board of
advisors but we have not had investors
for indie amplify and it's just because
it kind of took a life of its own and
has been crushing so now it's kind of
like
do this and i kind of got a game plan
for it for like the next few months and
then after that it's kind of like okay
what's really the end goal going to be
random futuristic bootleg head story we
got to tell the wiz khalifa story
okay we went to nau yes this was
flagstaff arizona yes
i believe wiz's cousin played football
there yes
i think he did a show at the i don't
[ __ ] know but anyway nau we go there
whiz and rocky i'm like i call
futuristic i'm like yo let's [ __ ]
let's hit let's hit i think i got into a
huge fight with my lady at the huge
fight she slapped you in the face
probably it was crazy why i'm not with
her anymore because she's a psychotic
[ __ ] she was definitely crazy he bought
her two very expensive bags and she was
very unappreciative she's a psychotic
[ __ ] um
anyone was playing video games on the
couch we end up going to flagstaff go to
flagstaff there's some house party
where's khalifa and all of the taylor
gang
ends up taking over this house party yes
it's like a very like stereotypical
college house in the mountains yeah
little three-story joint they got like a
[ __ ] the random offensive lineman's
bedroom is like the vip section facts
uh
and it was just a very weird night do
you remember the girl who smoked the
joint backwards and burned her gums off
maybe
i remember some dude you choked a whole
bottle of bombay
you were wasted
so wasted so let me tell you what
actually happens
we're at this party the girl went viral
on wiz's twitter the next day for
smoking the joint backwards and having
no idea she was smoking the joint
backwards burned her whole [ __ ] up whiz
posted it like
so that happened then you're like
dude
i can't [ __ ] drive and i'm like
i don't even know how to drive at this
point in my life i literally didn't know
how to do it you didn't know how to
drive you have a [ __ ] up jeep yeah
yeah and the alignment is like this
[ __ ] like this and i tell you i'm
like dude i can't drive so you're like
i'll drive we get five minutes up the
road this dude falls asleep and his jeep
is just going by the way you had sex in
that jeep that night no you had sex in
that net
this guy pulled a [ __ ] out of the
pirate and what you weren't with your
current girl who gives a [ __ ] no i
definitely wasn't no but yeah you pulled
the chick out there at the uh correction
correction we both had sex in the jeep
that night
actually be like yo i need the keys oh
man
something happened i don't i don't
remember only thing that i remember is
literally
swerving off the road and so i'm like
[ __ ] it i gotta make a life or that
decision i gotta drive don't have my
license don't know how to drive it is
what it is
i'm driving like this to keep it
straight in the next day
my arms were so sore from driving the
car i went to the gym to hoop and could
not shoot for [ __ ]
well that was a good night great night
shout out to whiz
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] that
happened
okay that show was also the first show
that wiz had done since he had his kid
so he was super excited just to be out
the house yeah it was a pretty wild
night he was living life and will was
doing some crazy [ __ ] i learned the
deodorant trick you remember the
deodorant trick they showed us stuff in
wheat in the deodorant
and all the deodorants dudes had like
150
things of deodorant and i'm like what
the [ __ ] going on weed in there they
opened up the caps all weed hides the
smell learned that yeah uh and saw naked
pictures of chelsea from teen mom on
somebody's phone that night chelsea from
team mom yeah
one of the taylor gang guys was
definitely a whole lot of gang [ __ ]
chelsea from teen mom shout out to will
was a great guy i love that guy one of
my best friends we are eskimo brothers a
few times over sheesh probably that
night yeah i don't know maybe it was a
good night though hey futuristic
appreciate you pulling up sir go support
indie amplify if you're a up-and-coming
artist
and you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing ah just go surf around the website
indieamplify.com come on
boom